here we are oh hi my name's Rhys helping
if you don't know now you know your life
is different now
straight is out what a confusing
statement squiggles are in if you guys
haven't seen there's this trend of
squiggle eyebrows and squiggle lips
happening and I'm not better than any of
that so I thought I'll jump on that
bandwagon I did high jump in high school
I'm very good at jumping but I'm gonna
raise it up enough and I'm gonna try and
do a full face of squiggles what does
that mean I don't know I don't fully
thought this through we're just gonna
wing it or squiggle it no winged
eyeliner here get out of here let's just
do this I have Foundation and concealer
already on my face so that step is done
I guess the first thing we're gonna do
we're gonna try some squiggle eyebrows
gonna use this Revlon Colorstay brow
pencil that I have that is too dark for
my eyebrows normally but might work
better for this scenario so let's try
that let me use the mirror that's in
this thing I'm assuming that you just
draw the squiggles and then you color
them in I've seen people like cut their
barrels into squiggles too but look I've
cut my bangs twice I'm not here for that
anymore
I'm in a better place emotionally all
right so let's just try and draw some
squiggle oh yeah it's sort of starting I
get when makeup gurus can't talk and do
their makeup at the same time okay I
think I found the flow that not so much
a squiggle as like someone doing a bad
dive into a pool yeah okay that's a
little bit more squiggle I'm gonna try
my other brow product to see if it
blends it better cabral by benefit that
I love so much maybe should have started
with it but really didn't help very much
but let's move on to the other eyebrow
whoa
these look like to ghost Buffalo's
charging at each other cue it's already
taking shape when the shape is a
squiggle it just it's this shape
now let's squiggle our eyeliner I'm just
gonna take some liquid liner that I have
and see if we can make some squiggles
this one's gonna be the bad one I think
I'll just squiggle the top oh not easy
why did we try this can you see that my
hands are shaking I think there's no
consequence to doing this but for some
reason I'm very nervous I want you guys
to think I'm good at something what that
something is I don't know oh come for me
boys she's ready
that's squiggled let's go
the other eye okay before it gets out of
hand let's move on oh we squiggle their
eyeliner okay now just put some mascara
on can't really squiggle that now I
wanted to try squiggling blush but I
don't think it's gonna show up very well
I have this Stila blood
I'll show using like a fine tool oh okay
that oh maybe this is a look good summer
look lend it out a little bit oh wow I
mean contour for the gods in hell
because this is a nightmare
here we go okay oh yeah one tool if I
give two weird hives for me on the side
of your face
that's sweet let's try the same for
bronzer we're use the same brush yes
there we go wow wow wow wow okay
very tribal meets a carnival finally
we're gonna squiggle our lips I'm going
to use this Too Faced melted Max
liquefied matte long-wear lipstick from
Candy Johnson's new line with Too Faced
I don't know if this is the best way for
me to be demonstrating her product but
hi candy I love this lipstick I'm gonna
use it here now we're just gonna try and
squiggle like we've been doing this
whole time it's good when you want to
overdraw your lips to give them a bigger
shape than you have naturally oh yes yes
so we kind of shut the bottom part of
the lips a little bit but you get the
picture I wanna mess with it too much
more capable let me just touch it a
second more okay and there we go there's
our full face of squiggle makeup what do
you guys think let me know hmm
I mean it's really impressive I know I'm
impressed look at this leave a comment
down below what you guys think and what
you would call this look I think I would
call this squiggly puff I'm very
dehydrated so I'm retaining water and my
face is a little puffy if you guys liked
this video give it a thumbs up and click
that subscribe button cuz I make videos
Monday Wednesday and Friday sometimes
sometimes I don't I don't know Wow
mm-hmm yeah I feel like a failed Pokemon
or like a sperm that went drag